Genisys is with us in Gainesville
Florida hi Genesis how are you I think
I'm good thank you so much for taking my
call
sure what's up well I'm a bit scared I
just got a notice in the mail to be
summoned to court for a credit card that
I haven't paid in a couple of months
because I've been out of work and I just
really don't know what to do I'm really
frantic and I want to pay these debts
but you know since there's so many made
it for it I don't know if I need to get
a lawyer if I should try to mediate it
myself I just need some type of guidance
please mm-hmm
it's not a couple of months it's a lot
of months yeah how many I'm gonna say
maybe since January or February
yeah like a year okay and who's the
credit card with include discover who
you know just Discover card straight up
okay yeah and the court that they have
summoned you to is where it's here in my
town okay and what do you are what do
you owe them 3,500 okay cool
and what do you you're still out of work
from a major city to a small town and
I've been looking for work for a couple
of months now and right now we're still
on one income I've gone to a couple of
interviews I have an interview tomorrow
but and I've paid off others so what
does your husband like he makes about
900 a week okay and and how much other
debt do you guys have my car on five
thousand
we have a couple of things like our well
at our house when we both we got a new
pump and that was like another 6,000 and
some credit cards and how much on credit
cards other than discover maybe like six
or seven thousand country including the
discover know with and the discover okay
Irene and I'm nervous that's okay that's
alright and how much is your house
payment okay and how long is your
husband been making nine hundred a month
I mean nine hundred a week I'm sorry how
long has he been making he just started
getting paid more a couple of months ago
maybe like June okay alright you guys
are completely disorganized you being
out of work is not the problem you guys
have no freaking idea where your money's
going
I don't yeah you're mathematically
clueless on where your money's going
because you're making enough to not be
behind on these bills with his income
alone mm-hmm
unless you left the debt out I mean you
got a $5,000 card at a six thousand
dollar well debt on a seven thousand
dollars in credit card debt
and a six hundred dollar house payment
you're making 50k a year how many kids
have you got disorganized and nobody's
paying attention you're driving down the
road and nobody's even holding the wheel
to the car you making this is making
sense because that I'm telling you you
got there's all kinds of room in this
math for y'all to have been able to pay
your bills since he's been making nine
hundred a week in June you should not be
getting sued yeah let me be nice to you
I'm gonna help you with this but then
I'm gonna be mean to you okay you've
been here responsible that's what I'm
trying to say you've not been paying
attention at all you guys are doing a
horrible job with your money
so let me get you out of this here's the
thing okay you can just ignore discover
if you want they're not gonna do
anything
is that discover in your name or your
husband's are both good so you don't
even have any income they can't do
anything so you know until you have an
income they can't come after your income
so we'll go back and fix them later the
bad news is they're suing you the good
news is this is your wake-up call it is
time to get organized focused
responsible quit partying and make every
one of these dollars behave how old are
y'all 24 yeah I'm 25 and 20 yeah okay
so by right all right so really time to
get serious like let's pretend I hired
you for a hundred thousand dollars a
year to manage this couple's money you
could do it you're not dumb you just
haven't paid attention am I wrong yeah
okay so I want you to go to Financial
Peace University our nine week class I'm
gonna pay for it and he's gonna go with
you you and your husband together can
you get him to go all right because you
need to get on top of this and you can
call discover and negotiate with him you
don't need an attorney you don't even
need to show up in court
you're gonna lose you oh I'm $3,500 and
you can work out a payment plan on the
judgment after it goes to judgment in a
couple weeks
it's not a big deal but and you're gonna
be completely out of debt by summer so
it doesn't matter you don't pay it all
off by summer so hold on we'll have
Kelly pick up and get you guys signed up
for Financial Peace University hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you